a week since prince philip died
peacefully the queen was a windsor
preparing to say
a final goodbye inside the grounds her
son
prince edward his wife the council of
wessex and their daughter lady louise
came to see the thousands of bunches of
flowers left outside of the castle
moved during the week and placed next to
saint george's chapel
where the funeral will take place
tomorrow
the service was always going to happen
here a place with special memories for
prince philip
and the queen who gave her husband the
responsibility
of ranger of the great park paul
sedgwick the deputy ranger
always enjoyed his time with the
challenging inquisitive duke
i think you just have to look over my
shoulder at the landscape
he had the foresight the vision to
replant many of the avenues
that future generations will see and i
think
history will judge his tenure as ranger
of the great park as a golden chapter
in the history in the long history of
windsor great park
but i suspect if the duke was looking
down on us now
he would probably do with i think quiet
reflection
with no fuss but he'd be the first to
tell us all to crack on
and get on with the job and that
character will come across
in his funeral with unique touches
requested by the prince
a man who enjoyed carriage driving well
into his 90s
his ponies and his carriage will be on
display as his coffin
is driven away the royal family say they
have felt genuinely touched by the
stories and memories that people have
shared of prince philip this week
and there is in a way a sense of sadness
that because of covid they're asking
people
not to come here to windsor but they're
hoping that by sharing the order of
service in advance people can still feel
part
of the occasion
[Music]
last summer prince philip appeared for a
rare public engagement with the rifles
regiment
on the spot where the funeral procession
will pass
his military family honored to have had
his leadership
we've taken so much from him over the
last 68 years he's given so much
and you know you can't stand
and listen to nimrod without the hairs
going up on the back of your neck
you're standing about three inches
taller you feel a tear in your eye
and just pinch yourself that you're able
to honor
his royal highness and be part of that
ceremony the pandemic has meant that
like so many other families
this will not be the goodbye that they
expected
a close family funeral but with cameras
still allowed inside
a display of their desire to share this
moment of
mourning for a dedicated consort and a
man
they loved very much rhiannon mills
sky news at windsor castle